I do this thing with my shows anyway
where it's like um if you want to go
alone to my show and you buy a ticket
alone which a lot of people have like oh
I'm gonna look like a loser whatever I
go
um I'll give you free meet and greet
which I generally you know it's part of
a VIP package or a charge for it because
not to be a dick but because you just
can't meet everyone so you got to put
some kind of like yeah and if you can't
afford I mean great I'm always just like
I'll just give you one but
um but I I will definitely give you a
free one if you go alone to a show and
then I'll you know say hi to you after
the show and stuff because it's I want
more people to go to comedy shows but I
think so many people miss out because a
lot of people who listen to podcasts and
who like comedy don't have that many
friends and that's not a dig like it's
hard to make friends it's hard to
maintain friends especially when you get
in your 30s and everyone gets partners
and kids 25 or 26 making new friends is
just it can be so brutal so hard and
finding the right person to go to a
comedy show with that might be very
raunchy like you don't want to bring a
first date necessarily you want to bring
your mom you don't want to bring your
sister so people struggle and it's like
I just encourage people go alone because
it's don't miss you will meet people
there and also I've never been to a
something and seen someone alone and
been like what a loser like there's no
part of me that would even I wouldn't
even clock it I don't think so I would
encourage also the theater is the best
place to go solo I feel to something
because it's like it's in the dark no
one's any advisor that you're solo I'm
going to Taylor Swift with um with my
fans like I didn't get Swift tickets and
so I was just put it out on my Instagram
like it sucks I didn't get any tickets
you know and people just started and I
wasn't even trying fishing and people
were like you can go with me and my
friends and I'm like just random fans
out there like we have four tickets and
if you want to go with us and so I'm
like I will go with fam
it's so awesome a crazy night for them
yeah like and I'll pay for the tick I'll
fly to you and pay for the ticket but
I'm I'm like re I will do anything I
mean it's very important to me to go to
as many of these shows as I can and and
it would be fun and I feel being a
Swifty I I identify more as a Swifty
than I do as a comedian or a woman or
anything I really do and so it's just a
commonality that you have with someone
me too
yeah do you feel are you truly a Swifty
though like big time really so don't you
feel like when you meet another hate
people from Oklahoma
I feel a kinship with them like I'm sure
your podcast listeners if they run into
each other and they both find out that
they listen to the show they're like oh
my God we're instant friends and that's
how I feel about other Taylor Swift fans
it's like you have this commonality that
is probably a deeper bonded that I share
with my most of my best friends you know
like you have this thing that you love
so much I mean do you guys have any
thing that you're obsessed with yeah
because my fiance is a huge Swifty as
well she now is like we got we got
tickets to one of the shows yeah and now
she's trying to get tickets for another
show because she's like I need to go to
multiple of these things the different
openers are you gonna do the same thing
you said I'm going not for the openers
just I just want to see her as much as
possible yeah I'm gonna go to as many as
like I'm gonna spend all of
I just bought tickets yesterday you know
six thousand dollars for three tickets
I know I just heard a gasp from the next
I mean and I'm not bragging like this is
I don't spend like this on anything I
live in a modest apartment in St Louis I
buy secondhand clothing I'm not a big
spit I don't I drive my mom's old beat
up Lexus I bought her a new carbide I'm
not someone who spends a lot but this is
like oh I can spend this insane amount
of money that would be like a trip to
Europe or the Middle East we don't know
really
um or I could go to this one night that
is the would be the best time of my life
in fact like I um I think if you're
Jewish you can go to Israel for free one
time right oh that's true yeah oh I wish
there was a Birthright for Taylor Swift
be awesome oh [ __ ] we gotta start that
like if you're like a a blonde white
girl who grew up on a Christmas tree
farm yeah you get um but you get you get
to go to free are you a Swifty yeah my
my uncle was yeah
that's right you're only supposed to
give your mother one yeah all right yeah
right yeah dude yeah you don't count you
do not count no I went to I go to Taylor
Swift listening parties that listening
parties but like Taylor Swift Out of
Here serious dude it's it's the best
time I've ever had in my life is going
have you ever been to one no okay so you
I would really recommend it yeah this
[ __ ] is religion you go crazy you go I
went to one in St Louis and they've had
they had at this point like three that
year so this is like an ongoing thing
listen to the music sold we sacrifice a
fan and then we always kind of hang out
and like just in our love for her
we smeared in with our period blood oh
Jesus
we burn an effigy of Jake Gyllenhaal
uh yeah sorry but it was it's so simple
so all you do is you go and there's like
five people on stage that like run the
event and they go around the country
they make so much [ __ ] money off of
Just pressing play and having like you
know they have a big screen with like
her music videos playing but there's not
any like real talent that goes into just
being like girls are you guys ready I
mean in you uh but like but it's mostly
a bunch of women and like and some gay
guys and like and guys with good taste
in music that might be yeah and um yeah
but I I think and I took my my boyfriend
went because at the time I was I had
vocal cord surgery so I couldn't speak
and so I needed like a translator with
me at all times and so he went with me
and he was like I've never seen a room
of people with so much joy for extended
Joy like uh just a two hour long joygasm
he was like I've never seen anything
like it these it was infectious he was
like kind of like scared of it at first
but he was like this is just magical and
people you they you get to go on stage
and like sing I brought in like a
microphone just to like hold to pretend
like I was like it was I was just a fan
that it was so much fun and so um my
goal for
2023 is to start a Taylor Swift cover
band and like start adding dates to my
shows like I go into town before or
after and I do a cover band of Taylor
Swift and I just donate the proceeds
because I just want to do it for fun
like I'm not trying to make money but
they're so there's such a built-in I
probably sell out bigger venues doing a
cover band for Taylor Swift than I would
my own hobby shows and it's the best
what's your favorite album oh that's a
great question it's actually my favorite
album is reputation and I know it's
shocking yes not a lot of swifties oh my
God that was the one that got me I was
going through like a tough time with a
guy and then you know delicate is my
favorite song of all time and then you
know ready for it just opening that
there was just like yeah I just I loved
it but then I think that's the tour that
I went to how long ago was that that was
a 2018 I think 17 18. yeah that's what I
went to oh it was a great it's the one
on yeah I was like I understand why this
is such a like why is this so like
electric for people because she really
like puts so much effort into yes yes
she just like I don't know it just makes
you
I just wish she would have been around
when I was in high school it just like
she helps me feel my feelings which are
all like [ __ ] pent up as hell you
know like you're you guys get it you're
boys you know like feelings they're hard
to access and especially as a comedian
like you just look at everything like
drywall it's so easy to get it out
that's how I express myself yeah it's
but comedy is like it's just so music is
so sincere and comedy is so insincere
and yeah I mean because I don't mean to
get all the net on you but like it's
like there's this thing of like
everything I can say something real but
I gotta cut it with a joke so I can get
really vulnerable but I gotta go but I'm
sure oh I'm gonna don't don't worry it's
not too real and music I mean like
there's like when you're singing it's
like you're like crying some men that
are like singing I'm like that's so
feminine almost they're like oh like
Neil Young's voice do you ever hear Neil
Young like The Coincidence
yes because think about Neil Young like
he's this like amazing rock star that's
just heralded as one of the best of his
generation or any generation and he
sings like this he sings like a little
he's he sings like you think Susan Boyle
would sound like like he's things like a
a woman but we like are like he's such a
[ __ ] rocker so uh there's something
for me that I feel like with comedy I'm
just kind of like it leaves something to
be desired for um just yeah yeah I agree
with that I mean hey man I'll try my
dump up there it doesn't go well yeah
you got to make it funny yeah and then
if you make it funny it kind of takes
away from the truth of it yeah do you
ever say something too real and people
are just like no man we don't relate to
that you should get some help you should
start marketing some shows as stand-up
trauma shows
where it's like it's not it's not common
I mean I've cut like a decent chunk of
[ __ ] out because some of it is just too
like when I talk about like kids getting
beat like Christian Youth in the midwest
like they just some of them get it
others are like what's your angle you're
talking about like childhood just like
getting beat as a kid no not me but like
you're talking about beating up children
yeah oh right when I pivot to that
no I bring a kid up there yeah the
demonstration is what really yeah man
I'll just like talk about like my
childhood and like my cousin still get
beaten oh I used to like act some of it
out and people would be like
you know what I love that because I feel
like that's that's what I want to go
towards is things that people go you
can't talk about that and it's like well
that's because getting beat as a kid is
so [ __ ] awful and there are kids
getting beat and we do need to talk
about it and yeah we're not making fun
of the victims of it we're talking about
it's a thing that's unless they make a
weird noise then it's funny yeah I'm
sorry
continue
I like that making people uncomfortable
with that stuff not to just make people
uncomfortable but to uh it's it's
actually being vulnerable it's not like
um you're not like hey